alright this is a Fox News Alert
congressman Devin Nunez he is now filed
just earlier tonight a multi-million
dollar federal racketeering lawsuit
against fusion GPS the congressman along
with Fox News contributor Sarah Carter
join me now with more congressman let's
talk about this that we now know that or
you're accusing them of literally
working with the campaign for
accountability to derail your
investigation and secondly other issues
tell us about well thanks Sean you've
done a great job covering this over the
last two and a half years as many people
know I was often smeared and now what we
know is there's a link between those who
are doing the smearing and fusion GPS
fusion GPS has a long career in this
they have a long record of this remember
they work for the Russian government or
oligarchs of the Russian government to
smear an American name bill Browder most
people know about the still dossier and
working to smear the Trump campaign when
we were investigating fusion GPS they
were actively involved in working to
smear me to obstruct justice to derail
our investigation and so you know I'm
gonna hold these guys accountable and
this is just one of many steps that we
continue to take because we have to go
to the courts just like Jay Sekulow was
saying we have to go to the courts so
our third branch of government we're
gonna have to rely on them to fix a lot
of this mess what do you think when when
Special Counsel Muller didn't know who
fusion GPS was nor did he know Jeannie
Rae once worked for Clinton Sarah's
laughing it's funny in one way but it's
not funny in a big way right well look
the reason the reason why he did no
because he wasn't really engaged in this
investigation the whole time and this is
part of the reason why we have to go to
the courts we know that we spent forty
million dollars roughly investigating
the Trump campaign but at the end of the
day we don't have anything to show for
it
we don't know many of the players that
were involved in the Russian
investigation and to not know who Fuzion
GPS is you know give me a break this is
why the courts are gonna have to come in
and clean this up and this is why people
like me who have the ability to do this
to take these cases to court so that we
can pull out more information because
ultimately people have to be held
accountable and I don't think we can
rely on just on the Department of
Justice individuals who are out there or
groups who are out there need to take
these cases individually to court you
know Sarah saw your piece today the
Senate must hold the the investigative
hearing top Obama officials need to be
held accountable when you couple that
with what Jay Sekulow was saying along
with Comey light there's no ambiguity
here because he verified the dossier was
true it was the bulk of information to
apply for those FISA warrants he signed
off on him three times in the interim
between two of them he told Donald Trump
that it was not verified and denied that
Trump was actually being investigated
when he knew better because he was
leading that investigation and he also
lied when he said it isn't spy because
that warrant allows spying
right we need the Senate to conduct an
investigation alongside what John Durham
is doing right now the US Attorney and
William bar Shawn it's the only way the
American public is going to get to the
truth so the only place that we can have
a hearing right now is in the Senate I
mean a Senator Lindsey Graham can hold a
hearing with the judiciary the Senate
Judiciary Committee it's powerful he can
do this now we can also look at Chuck
Grassley senator Grassley and as far as
fusion GPS is concerned shine they are
the epicenter the epicenter of what I
call a soft coup on the president of the
United States
absolutely what devin newness is doing
right now the congressman is doing the
right thing by suing them because they
are going to have to give up information
and this appears to be the only way is
by suing people like this and core 10
companies this private entity which was
working with the Russians we know they
were connected to previs on holding we
know they were connected to Natalia
vessel mitts kaya we which was the
Russian attorney remember that went to
go meet with Don junior so we know that
all of this was happening and of course
Christopher Steele and we also know that
Comey isn't telling the truth like you
said as well as John Brennan James
clapper
amantha power when masked 300 people
Susan Rice Barack Obama be held
accountable this would have been his
counterintelligence investigation
congressman's were expected in the
Pfizer report from the inspector general
to me anything short of these warrants
were illegally obtained premeditated
fraud they were warned we've chronicled
that they were unverifiable its author
doesn't stand behind it the FBI finally
determined himself it wasn't true but
that was long after they signed the
warrant should have been ahead of time
between that FISA report premeditated
fraud on a court and the Durham report
do you believe that we will see equal
justice under the law an equal
application of our laws and do you think
these figures we talked about will in
fact face indictment and possible
convictions well you know that we've
sent over criminal referrals what I
would focus on is conspiracy because
because I think that's the religious
actors in the criminal essentially
people know in the legal sense it's
conspiracy in the criminal sense and
Greg Jarrett's explained it very well in
your show many times but you know they
defrauded the u.s. they lied to the FISA
Court they abused Carter Paige is his
right so there's there's lots of laws
that were broken that can fit under
conspiracy and it's about putting all
that together in a package just where
are Allied intelligence agencies used
spy on Americans and a sitting president
or president-elect or presidential
tantor we I mean of course we yeah we I
mean we know that I mean that was the
whole and that was the whole point of us
putting out the information when they
were spying on Carter Paige that was
used to go after the Trump campaign but
I will tell you it's it's gonna take
everyone working together in this all
all the American people that want to get
to the truth this is why it's so
important that that lawsuits are brought
to the courts okay so you see that with
its judicial watch it's it's what we're
doing it's what Jay Sekulow was doing
all of this has to have
to pull this information out because as
you know the deep state is very good at
hiding things and so in order to get at
it you have to work every day to pull
back pieces of this onion well last
question Sarah Carter if the warrants
were illegally obtained and the outs or
spying on Americans at a presidential
candidate transition and president then
the question is who's going to be held
accountable here and you know I hear
it's going to be devastating if those
warrants were illegally obtained and
they were warned it was premeditated
lying to the FISA Court to obtain those
warrants and then we outsource something
that would circumvent American law to
spy on American citizens the you know
what would happen a Hannity test is
Hannity goes to jail or what would
happen any American citizen they go to
jail
that's right anybody would go to jail
Sean and what we're seeing now and I
like the use of the word conspiracy in
the legal sense because what we've seen
is a vast network not only spying
overseas but spying within the White
House which is what the ACLJ is looking
into and what Devon newness is looking
into which is fusion GPS being at the
epicenter of all of this and I'd like to
know what John Brennan knows I'd like to
know when he knew about that dossier if
he leaked that dossier to people in the
gang of eight in particular and how far
that web spread because once we know
those answers we will know who to indict
and who to charge and I'm sure that is
exactly what John Durham is doing all
right thank you both I'd like to send an
invitation a Jim Comey tonight mr. super
Patriot I'll give you the full hour on
this show to explain unverified
salacious and verified on top of a FISA
warrant both before and after you lied
to the president